my parents were from different worlds
and I was a product of the love that
never should have been could unite our
worlds one day
a son of the land and the son of disease
and what I always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the bridge between land and sea
take your rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now
oh yeah close to what dying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far
inland check this place out
it's real
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert you do your best
thinking when you're not thinking at all
right now hold still Hey
what are you doing we need water you're
the closest source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
you seek my power journey beyond the
edge of the world to the hidden sea
in the real hands
it won't bring destruction
but enhance the Trulia
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you oh yeah
what are you just say something
something Trident the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
who the hell are you
[Music]
[Music]
oh is awesome
the war is coming to the surface
you are not going to win this
billions will die unless you help us
I'm no leader
not King
[Music]
clintus who's always had a key now I
need something more
what could be greater than I can
[Music]
a hero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]